hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares I went through 5 in the last
50 levels I went through five of those
three part maze ones that you have to
sort through and it took me forever
because each one of them was not one of
the patterns that I already know so now
I get to deal with this the forest of
Diamond ears again and this time I'm not
gonna be caught off guard no siree Bob
no siree way neither could screw those
deer my god they are awesome and
horrible and it's the first new thing
that I've seen that it's actually like a
dynamic entity so good for it and just
in time too I got my axe
how many more rooms are there by the by
I want to go Bambi I know you want
revenge I am not the hunter so go screw
yourself thank you very much
no uh okay no no I'm gonna panic
I got a panic it all only one of them's
after my blood god they make a weird
what is this well this is all
interesting and good and awesome but I'm
out of here
I don't have time to appreciate wool oh
come on
what is no that was that's new that's
different dance no this is no I think I
gotta make it to six hundred thousand
make sense if I could get to six hundred
I guess it's gonna be the end of all
this cuz it seems to be culminating I
really hope that it ends as to what is
happening to my screen why is the
revolution all flung feet up never mind
I can talk why do I have a veneer of the
troller
so what I'm hearing something obviously
is not correct here but I mean what
specifically is not correct because I've
seen WTF things in this already but I'm
gonna say right now those dear where
some of the scariest monsters I've ever
seen in horror games by par I would like
to not mess with them ever again but I
would also like to know and what the
hell is going on with my screen is there
something following me no okay
usually when something like this has
happened you are there way too early mr.
jelly man oh now it's gone well now it's
cleared up the jelly man scared them all
away okay good to know to know there's
my little mini jump scares are there to
aid me and not kill me they've only
killed poor old people with weak hearts
but then again what our poor old people
with weak hearts doing in this place
anyway gotta mow was there only a few
more to go come on don't give me any of
the white rooms I don't wanna do I don't
want a puzzle I hate puzzles hate these
puzzles anyway tired of them give me the
room 600 so I can see what the hell is
at the end of this road doing it for so
long now I really didn't expect to be
playing this game all the way through I
will admit that right now but he did
intrigued me so many things in this game
that just piqued my curiosity come on
was there that's gonna be nothing at
least I hope that's nothing because it
actually is something one of these times
I'm supposed to check I will be very oh
goddamn it nope ping nope got Mouse
yeah I did it God for once it didn't
take forever ray I'm probably gonna do
it yet another one of those before the
end of this oh I really hope the end of
this is actually some sort of a payout
because if it's not well oh this again
they're actually gonna be a reason for
this or is this cuz I'm Pro tching room
600 nothing gonna happen
yay yay okay last jump scared oh god
damn it there's more
hang in there screw you what more could
there be
why is there another working elevator
what are you not telling me
are there really gonna be a thousand
rooms in this game I can't do it I can't
play it all the way to the end oh I got
a packs to prepare for yeah I get
through your Resident Evil door oh also
Fatal Frame 2 is unfortunately going to
be delayed I said that I was gonna play
that game but unfortunately the disk is
scratched and it won't load up on the
Erin's xbox also known as egoraptor he
grabbed his xbox here at the game grub
studios also I won't be at the game drum
studios much longer I just like
recording here it's nice but I'm gonna
be setting up my own that was a mistake
apparently I'm gonna be setting up my
own little space uh soon I'll be back in
order and everything will be hunky-dory
hey uh homeotic what passes point is not
completed yet
the only reason keep going out score
I've been down Evangeline No ah I come
all this way looking for a pound it's
not done it's not done ah
I was all no no no 6 Jen was supposed to
have a new monster
oh well I guess I shouldn't be too upset
this means I can actually move on to
other no ah came all this way often
nothing is that just a trick see
triggers app for realsies I guess is for
realsies so anyway got it just got
interesting with the deer and the spooky
sending me back but actually going
forward that was nice all right guess
that's the end of it for now
don't know what's gonna happen after I
exit the game but either way I thank you
guys for joining me for this journey
once again I'd like to say I'm currently
at PAX when you see this and I'm
currently hanging out with some of you
guys some probably have had my panel by
now maybe it's up on Polaris or my
channel I don't know exactly where
that's going but hey thanks for meeting
with me in the future thanks for being
there for me in the future and thank you
everybody who is in here with me in the
past or present or in the future beyond
packs because this video could be
watched by somebody in the year 2029 or
of 30 47 or 69 69 which is gonna be a
really great year and let's just you
know everyone's pass it joke by then and
gosh I hope not I hope we don't grow up
by then but either way thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
with chica chica